hi my name is kita where you want on the
chairman of the investment morning
report for the Republic of Indonesia on
a question of what beats want a leader
first many answers this is a topic that
has been digested and thought off by
many people and such that the leadership
theory has become a multi-billion dollar
business but my take on this is quite
simple I think leadership it is we need
about selfless service and in a service
and sense that you know you're in the
business of meeting others so that they
can become better off in the future and
it is selfless and sense that you know
you gotta make sure that you gotta have
the courage and you're gonna have the
bravery to basically face and confront
anybody that might try to resist the
post or even under my name so I think
that's an important part of leadership
thanks